Frank Castle got something I need to
show Russia the video files the US
military turns you over hitman Frank
Castle it's the last witness we can
either clean this up or let them take us
down we'll need to see the truth hey
everybody Punisher is dropping this
Friday this is gonna be my non-spoilery
review of the series so far they've only
released the first half of the season to
critics so obviously there's a bunch of
plot lines that they set up a bunch of
different characters that have arcs to
sort of weave and intersect throughout
the season that will all come together
by the end or at least that's the idea
the series works as well as you hope it
will they'll all make sense together and
the Punisher will find a solution for
everything so if you're just finding me
for the first time be sure to subscribe
to get everything
I'll be doing more easter-egg breakdowns
as we get through the weekend just
depending on how quickly everybody gets
through episodes sometimes people take a
little bit longer like usually people
burn through daredevil a little bit
faster than series like Jessica Jones or
Luke Cage but I'll also try to place
this in the context of those other
series it sort of ranked my favorite
Netflix marble seasons and I know
there's a lot of talk about maybe Disney
pulling all of the Netflix content
regardless of what they do in future
seasons there will be more seasons of
these shows so don't worry about that
but leading the cast you have Jon
Bernthal who does a master performance
of the character best version of the
characters so far even after a daredevil
season 2 you would have said he's
probably one of the best versions of the
character but whereas he's more of a
backup character you only see a little
bit of him during daredevil season 2 you
get like the full enchilada you get the
backstory they sort of updated it for a
modern context if you read him in the
comics you know he's a Vietnam vet now
he's a veteran of the war in Iraq and
the war in Afghanistan and just a person
having trouble dealing with civilian
life so post-traumatic stress survivor
guilt
those are big parts of his arc you know
about jigsaw you know about Rollins you
know about micro Karen Paige is the
primary crossover character there's a
new character that's not from the comics
named Dinah Madani who has this really
big story arc that parallels a lot of
the veterans story arcs like Frank
Castle and the other people
that he meets with he has a veteran
support group that he goes to interacts
with some other characters so that
becomes part of his storyline the series
itself sort of like the big overarching
themes take a really hard look at the
military intelligence industrial complex
in the age of the war on terror because
that's sort of when the wars took place
that Frank was a part of so it also
takes a really hard look at the idea of
these big governmental organizations
taking really dissatisfied young people
and turning them into killing machines
and what happens to them when their
government is done with them but just
sort of leaving them to dry there's a
conspiracy aspect to the show there's
something he's trying to uncover Rollins
is sort of the de facto kingpin villain
type character for the series and he was
their commanding officer when they were
in Afghanistan they were a military unit
like you've seen in the trailers that
were forced to commit a lot of war
crimes so part of the conspiracy
storyline is them uncovering sort of the
larger things at play where the Rollins
characters hiding out committing all
kinds of crimes against humanity wearing
the badge of patriotism then as you have
all that going on in the background you
have Frank's internal journey as he
deals with the loss of his family like
obviously he's trying to get the people
that killed his family but he also
himself did a lot of terrible things in
Afghanistan but the series tries to take
a really intelligent stance on violence
like the violence that he in acts as
he's taking down even worse people doing
bad things to take down even worse
people I think the message is is that
he's never going to be absolved of the
terrible things that he did but he'll
just become a much more balanced person
he'll be able to put it into perspective
so even though it's a big part of his
character the series in no way condones
violence and that's where you basically
get the jigsaw character because he says
squadmate back in Afghanistan so they
have these parallel arcs where you know
they both don't quite know how to fit
back in now that there's civilians again
jigsaw just fights that in a very
different way from the Punisher the war
that the Punisher is fighting is more
like an internal war in a war against
domestic terror through the Rollins
characters storyline and then sort of
parallel to all that you have the Dynamo
Donnie character who's at homeland
security and the really interesting
thing about her is that she's this
Middle Eastern character who is actually
really good at her job
but because she's Middle Eastern people
view her with this lens of suspicion
because this is the age of the war on
terror so in the way that society
doesn't really know what to do with
veterans when they come back from a war
it's also the same thing with her
character like they're not quite sure
what to do with her inside Homeland
Security even though she's really good
at her job she's sort of the odd man out
so to speak and the thing is is that
obviously the Punisher does really
terrible things so she learns about him
and tries to take him down but at the
same time she's tried to uncover the
same conspiracy that Frank and Mike
wrote together or trying to uncover so I
think the idea is is in the back half of
the season she's probably going to find
that she will need the Punisher just as
much as she thinks she needs to take him
down so it's one of those push-pull
things with law enforcement and
vigilantes like you have the daredevil
character the police can't officially
sanction what Matt does at night but
they need him because they can't do
everything by themselves but the
interesting thing about the way the
series picks up is because we haven't
seen the Punisher since daredevil season
2 like he says
see you around red there is a little bit
of visual continuity with the way they
shoot the first episode so it feels very
much like Punisher during daredevil
season 2 before the tone of the series
changes just a little bit and you get
into core Punisher stuff so overall the
first half of the season sets up some
interesting plot lines I think a lot of
people are just hoping that they all
connect by the end of the series and I
think most of the people I've seen
complaining about it are mostly
complaining about the more violent
aspects of the show especially given the
context of what's been happening in real
life in the last couple of months
like they push the release just a little
bit because of a couple very public
buried tragic shootings but like I said
the series actually does take a very
intelligent stance on the idea of
violence and the reason why the Punisher
does the things that he does probably
one of the best characters besides the
Punisher though is Mike Rowe so like
most people are thinking about Karen
page because you know her from all the
other series if you know Mike Rowe from
the comics this version is a little bit
different albeit he feels like he's
right out of a Garth eNOS comic and
obviously there's a lot of punisher max
within this series but it pulls from a
bunch of different places so you punish
a war general Punisher max
Punisher proper so you don't have to
read any of the comics but if you're big
Garth eNOS fan there's probably gonna be
a lot more Easter eggs as we get through
the series but I think the series really
does pick up once Punisher starts
working with micro once they start
bouncing off of each other because the
Punisher character usually works best
when he's a backup character it's a
little weird to see him take the
forefront so that's why I think they're
gonna try as hard as they can to use
Frank in the other series going forward
now they haven't confirmed where he's
gonna pop up after this season but the
thing that the Netflix series have been
doing for the last couple of years is
that it doesn't always do a new season
every single year sometimes is every
year and a half they probably won't drop
that born-again Ark till this time next
year my guess is is that he will pop
back up during that because like he said
see you around read that see around part
will probably be the born-again
storyline next year so what'll happen is
is I'll talk about how the series is
connected in more specific ways Easter
eggs and how they connect to the Marvel
Universe when I start doing Easter Egg
stuff this weekend so be sure to check
it out all the episodes drop Thursday
night midnight Pacific time so in
related news the Justice League premiere
is today is I'm posting this video so
I'm supposed to be doing some special
stuff for that I'm not allowed to post
my review for that till Wednesday night
so that's when that'll post but there'll
be much more comic book stuff happening
the flash so just look at the top pin
comment for the videos that are be
coming next I'm still doing that
IMAX take a giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video I'll just announce
the winner the next time I post a Marvel
video so while you wait for everything
you can click here for the last big
punisher trailer and you can click here
to learn all about the Thor Ragnarok
deleted scenes and alternate post
credits thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight